foreign
good afternoon I look forward to meeting
the EU defense ministers
NATO EU cooperation has been close to my
heart
for many many years and we are making a
lot of progress the war in Ukraine
demonstrates the importance of NATO and
the European working closely together
and uh
NATO allies and the EU has delivered
unprecedented support to Ukraine
just over the last months we have
delivered heavy battle tanks the
leopards the
the UK British Challengers but also now
the U.S Abrahams and then the last weeks
the United Kingdom has delivered
Advanced long-range cruise missiles
which are all the making a difference on
the battlefield and then of course over
the last days we have heard an
announcement from several allies
including the United States United
Kingdom and and several European allies
that they will start the training of
pilots on NATO standard modern Western
fighter jets
this demonstrates our redness to stand
by Ukraine and and to be prepared for a
long haul but of course to continue our
support Ukraine we also need to ramp up
production or weapons and over of
ammunition and therefore one of the
issues I will discuss with the defense
ministers is how we we can work even
more closer together NATO and the
European Union on increasing and
strengthening our
transatlantic industrial base I welcome
the work the eu's doing this is
making a difference is helping our joint
efforts
at the same time
what NATO does is also critical because
we are setting the standards to ensure
interoperability interchangeability we
have the NATO guidelines the capability
targets for each and every Ally and we
are now in the process of revising the
guidelines the kpt targets for uh battle
decisive ammunition which includes also
155 ammunition which is a critical piece
of ammunition in the war in in Ukraine
and and we are engaging closely with
industry I met them several times we
have we have engaged for them and I see
now that more and more NATO allies are
actually signing contracts which is what
we need to ensure that production
actually increases we need to avoid
creating new barriers between NATO
allies we need to strengthen the
transatlantic industrial base to ensure
that we can both replenish our own
stocks to ensure our own returns and
events but also to continue new to
support Ukraine
uh then another topic which was also
related to the war in Ukraine is the
protection of critical infrastructure
we have seen the vulnerability of
infrastructure especially under the
infrastructure
we have established a Joint Task Force
with the European Union NATO and the
European Union on critical on resilience
including infrastructure NATO has
established a cell at NATO to coordinate
efforts of of different countries
different allies and the public and the
private sector to step up what we do to
protect the critical infrastructure and
I expect also new announcements and
decisions at the upcoming NATO Summit so
then I'm ready for your questions
you mentioned there and are enforced the
European Union and NATO allies doing
everything possible to get enough
ammunition to Ukraine in the time frame
that Ukraine needs it are you confident
about the EU three-track approach is
there anything more you will be
encouraging them to do today
it is extremely important that we
increase the production of ammunition
this is something we have been focused
on for some time now since last fall we
have the first meetings at the at NATO I
also met with uh with Minister collierba
and uh Center and me we met at uh some
months ago and agreed also to coordinate
all the efforts between Ukraine EU and
NATO even more more closely
because it is always of course important
to discuss new platforms planes battle
tanks air defense systems but as
important or perhaps even more important
is it to ensure that all the systems
which are already in Ukraine work and
function as they should and to do so
they need ammunition they need fuel
spare parts maintenance and air capacity
so so the sustainment which also include
ammunition is absolutely critical this
is now a war of attrition and a water
attrition becomes a battle of logistics
and then production
ramp or production is absolutely key so
of course we are always focusing on what
more can we do to ensure that we engage
even more with industry that we mobilize
even more contracts we have I I have
decided to invite
um representatives from the defense
industry from both sides of Atlantic to
our defense ministerial meeting next
month to an event where we will engage
directly with all the ministers and the
defense industry the EU is of course
also invited Ukraine is invited to the
same event with um
with a higher representative Burrell but
also commercial to ensure the fullest
possible engagement with the defense
industry innate of course we have tried
and tested structures for uh production
and for also joint procurement we have
done joint procurement meaning Allah
buying ammunition and weapons together
for many many years
we have a big ongoing projects some of
them are organized by NATO allies as
groups many of them are organized
through the NATO support and procurement
agency the nsba and there are ongoing
projects now and I I I think of course
it's important to use all the tools
available including the well-established
NATO structures to coordinate and to
ensure joint procurement and and to sign
the contract so the industry is willing
to invest and run for production
foreign
I think it's a good idea and I welcome
the decision by several NATO allies
including Germany to start training or
Pilots because that gives us the
opportunity the possibility to make
decisions on also delivery later on
I will leave it to individual allies to
make announcement exactly about when
they start training but of course also
with the announcement about President
Biden this weekend
the U.S Being of course the main
provider of for instance f-16s and also
announcing clearly that they will start
training this is this is an important
step that partly will enable us to then
deliver a fighter jets at some stage but
also uh well is sending a very clear
signal that we are there for the long
term and and that Russia cannot wait us
out uh and and and and Preston Putin
started this war he can end this war and
we have to remember what this is this is
the water aggression
um Ukraine has the right of self-defense
they are defending themselves uh and and
the right of self-defense is enshrined
in the U.N Charter uh we help Ukraine to
uphold that right that's our right to
help them protect you and law
international law against the war of
aggression
um that doesn't make NATO or NATO allies
party to the conflict but we are
supporting Ukraine to defend themselves
against a war of aggression uh brutal uh
Invasion by by President Putin the
Japanese training
the Germans are among the countries that
have said that they are ready to to to
look into the issue over over of
training if I'm if I'm misinformed Then
I then I will get that
the fact that NATO is not ready to send
troops it is obvious that there is no
victory for poor ukrainians in the
battlefield how would you comment on
that
well what we have demonstrated now is
the willingness of NATO allies to really
Provide support to Ukraine and we have
seen that this support has been uh
really decisive uh President Putin made
several big strategic mistakes when he
invaded Ukraine
um uh partly because he totally
underestimated the ukrainians The
Bravery their their determination their
their their courage but also a totally
understand NATO allies and partners when
it comes to our willingness our
Readiness to provide support to Ukraine
and uh and uh and uh and this has
enabled ukrainians to to to push back
and to retake territory we saw it in the
north around Kiev where they actually
liberated a lot of territory then we saw
it in the East and around Harker and
then we saw it in the South again Hassan
so the ukrainians have already
demonstrated the capability they they
have to liberate land to push back the
the Russians and the importance of the
support they get from NATO allies then
of course they need to do more and
that's exactly why we are stepping up
our support I just mentioned the battle
tanks the the the long range cruise
missiles and are also training over
pilots and let me come back to exactly
which nations which are training Pilots
but but anyway several allies have
announced that they are attaining pilots
so I'm absolutely confident that Ukraine
has the capacity the will the courage
but also NATO allies have the have the
have the commitment the resolve to
support them so they can liberate and
and ensure that that President Putin
does not win this war thank you very
much thank you
foreign